I wonder mr. Williams if you might say a
word a word to us I deliberately don't
want to color this question much more
but I wonder if you might say a word to
us about the power that music is
pregnant with to help us connect and
even a time as we revel in the humanity
of the character and I think that I
don't purport to speak for everybody in
this room but I think I can on this one
which is to suggest that when we see
film the films that work best for us
while the FEMA for we can connect to the
humanity in the character it is a magic
and an evening like this it would it
isn't a bad idea to quote Alfred
Hitchcock who said I don't think exactly
word for word but in film music
represents the words that cannot be
spoken and music unites entire peoples
unites entire religions its power is
very great I don't think any of us
really fully understand how it works
Leonard Bernstein and his lectures would
tell us all the universality of the of
harmony the the overtone series and so
on which many people will understand but
a dough is a dough and the soul is the
soul or wherever you are in the world is
the division of sound is in nature and
this applied like gravity to every human
being and so even though harmonic
vocabulary from one culture to another
differs and there's a certain
acculturation that takes place with a
certain progression of harmony if it's
Wouter and so on that we respond to
people outside of the languages may not
quite respond in the same way but it is
true when Bernstein was trying to
demonstrate always where Noam Chomsky
was trying to demonstrate universalities
in language like the word mama
there are tremendous universalities in
music as he explained to us my attempts
to try to support these films and reach
people through what they hear is mostly
really an intuitive thing and the
application of the module Ettore
structures of music and so on
manipulations if you like
I mean it's recomposing for me is really
like sculpting I mean you really take a
chunk out of the stone another chunk and
finally it reveals itself what's inside
the stone we didn't know when we began
we will find it
we are not always successful but in my
case of course I talked to half an hour
or so ago about the orchestra the
expressive power and performance of
music is also another great thing you
and I chatted about our mutual friend
Jesse Norman earlier in the evening what
Jesse would take the stage and she would
unite everyone in the audience with her
heart with her training with her voice
with her gift and Gustavo is a magician
he will conduct the whole Mahler cycle
without a score the whole Beethoven
cycle if I would study Mahler for 700
years ago stuff I couldn't do that
hahaha this is an extraordinary gift
people in their heart those among us
with these kinds of very very special
unique gifts you use two words a moment
ago and I want to ask a question I'm
only being half or part silly with it
but you used the word intuition and
manipulation just a moment ago
I wonder given this immense gift that
you have whether or not you ever feel
guilty the way you manipulate our
feelings the way the way you evoke the
way you evoke out of us mr. Tom
identification the way you evoke out of
us what you want it's a wonderful gift
but you really play with our emotions
man you feel guilty about it well
welcome baby but if you late was not a
world chosen word maybe the exercise of
a certain craft might be about a better
way of putting it but I think we may
have in certain scenes a genuine
emotional target right we want to touch
people in a certain way if an aggressive
way or a gentle way of soothing we're
healing way all of these things will be
in your mind if it's to be healing what
does that there's so much of the process
of how we learn our language our general
education and acculturation and so on
all of these things are all linked
together and all of us who work in
communication which is what music is
really all about essentially deals with
finding connections I always think I
would stop by saying it isn't the music
it isn't the orchestra it isn't the
composer
it's the connection or the audience it's
the connective link the Nexus the
linking of all of that together composer
I'm just a guy who puts dots on the
paper means nothing Gustavo conducts an
orchestra plays if the audience hears
that it is this inter connect
interconnection of all of these elements
that makes music music watch my time I'm
gonna move on but just between the two
of us nobody's listening just between
you and me but there have to be moments
when you're sitting at your at your desk
or your workstation wherever you work
when you write something you say I'm
gonna kill them with this one I'm I'm
gonna get on with this with when they
hear this oh god the teeth you between
the two of us you've had those moments
haven't you John with us
come on man keep it this way there are
moments when I'm more secure than other